holding pictures of their loved ones
relatives of the victims of
extrajudicial killings streamed into
this hearing in the northeast region of
catatumbo
where 10 former military members among
them a general admitted to committing
war crimes and ask for forgiveness
i killed family members of people who
are here i misled them and cruelly and
cowardly assassinated them pretending
they were rebels tarnishing their name
leaving children without fathers mothers
with our children i know you won't
forgive me but i hope this will avoid
this happening again the military's
supposed to protect farmers they trusted
us and we lied to them and killed them
facing each other victims and
perpetrators detailed the killing of
over a hundred civilians falsely
portrayed as rebels killed in combat
the court determined that 6 402 people
were murdered this way between 2002 and
2008 in a scandal known as false
positives the goal was to boost debt
statistics and justify u.s military aid
the soldiers involved were rewarded with
promotions and time off
the requirement was to produce
casualties in combat no matter what this
according to the policies of the army
commander a demand repeated in different
equilibriums of command
officers explained how they planned the
killings making lists of vulnerable
farmers disabled people in ute
they said they conspired with
paramilitary groups that offered them
weapons and uniforms to disguise the
killings
many victims are wondering why there has
been so much impunity
why did we have to make a public scandal
for fourteen years to reach this point
what would have happened if we had given
up
did we need another six thousand 6 402
victims
the court that you see behind me is also
investigating the military high command
that has always denied that the killings
were part of a systematic policy but a
number of officials have said that they
were under pressure to inflate the
success of their military operations
these weren't isolated events nor bad
apples responsible for the killings this
is the result of failed state policies
and this is what the judiciary hasn't
determined yet
but despite the trial's limitation the
fact that the soldiers are admitting
that they committed war crimes is
unprecedented
in an important step in overcoming one
of the darkest chapters of colombia's
long civil conflict alessandra
al jazeera bogota